we have yet another trump appointee who
sadly while I guess sadly for him good
for the country is resigning from his
job this time because of the revelation
that he was posting crazy birther
nonsense to his Facebook page Todd
Johnson is his name he ran New Mexico
for the Trump campaign back in 2016 he
got a job at the Department of Defense
last year that already is kind of weird
he was hired at the gs-14 pay level
which is usually for quite senior civil
service positions we don't know why
Johnson was hired at that level but in
any case CNN started looking into this
guy and they found that he had posted a
whole bunch of birther conspiracies
about Barack Obama he shared videos that
claimed Barack Obama was the Antichrist
to his Facebook page and yet again we
are a laughingstock right Johnson was
working alongside the defense secretary
Jim mattis he would travel with mattis
this is not once again I'm using this
term Johnson was not some coffee boy he
was a gs-14 Department of Defense
employee working directly with the
Secretary of Defense Jim mattis and some
of the videos that Johnson shared to
Facebook include one called Michelle
Obama admits Barack Obama's home country
is Kenya a friend of Johnson's commented
that Obama being a Muslim makes him
crazy - which Johnson replied yes sir
and Johnson also shared a story that
joked about Obama being murdered after a
crash of Air Force One in rural Kentucky
why are there different standards for
different people
so Todd Johnson has been forced to
resign because he was parroting birther
nonsense on Facebook wasn't Trump kind
of the birther in chief Trump made
birther statements and was elected
president and Johnson posted some stuff
to Facebook and he's forced to resign a
birther resigned from the Department of
Defense but the de facto public leader
of the birther movement is the President
of the United States
Trump bragged about sexually assaulting
women and he was elected president Billy
Bush laughed about it in the same
recording and lost his job at Access
Hollywood Trump slammed Hillary Clinton
for her handling of sensitive
information as a
she shouldn't be elected president and
then Trump gives away secrets from an
ally to Russian spies in the Oval Office
and the committed Trump estill defend
the guy and for those who sing well
listen Trump doesn't believe the birther
stuff anymore that's what it appears to
be at the end of 2017 I told you this
was only five months ago that it was
widely reported that Trump privately was
still saying he's not sure about the
legitimacy of Obama's infamous long-form
birth certificate and we found out about
it because some of the people in the
room were so distraught over the fact
that Trump was still talking about this
that they felt it necessary to leak word
of those conversations to the media now
I genuinely don't know why Todd Johnson
has had to resign because it just
there's no evidence that this is a
disqualifier there's no evidence that
being a birther makes any difference
when the president believed that stuff
and was still elected I just don't get
it just different standards I guess well
maybe it's because Todd Johnson joked
about the president getting killed the
president being Obama of course and that
Obama was the Antichrist
I mean that seems to me like it's
clearly hyperbole whereas the birtherism
stuff was a conspiracy theory for sure
but still somewhat mainstream if people
like Trump are going to support it yeah
I mean I think it's a distinction but
it's not not really a difference and you
know we're not gonna dig into the
birther stuff anymore but I still don't
get why it even matters where Obama was
born since his mom was unquestionably
American like whether Obama was born in
London or Indonesia or Kenya or wherever
the birthers are still wrong in
principle on the entire thing but I
think at this point the ship has sailed